[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis schönen abend und
willkommen zu den nachrichten viel
fußball von norbert lehmann junior von
mir und im parlament ging es heute zur
sache
schlagabtausch im bundestag in der
generaldebatte
attackiert cdu-chef märz die regierung
scharf ganzer stolz weist die vorwürfe
energisch zurück
krachen atomkraft minister herbert will
kernkraftwerke als notstrom reserve
technisch nicht möglich sagt jetzt ein
betreiber
und fehlstart in die champions league
leipzig verliert und feuer trainer
tedesco
selten hat man kann stolz so emotional
und angriffslustig erlebt mit
oppositionsführer und
unionsfraktionschef märz lieferte er
sich heute ein heftiges wortgefecht in
der generaldebatte im bundestag
dabei ging es vor allem beim thema
energie krise hoch her mehr dazu von
peter spiekermann
bundeskanzler scholz streng grußlos vor
der debatte gewohnt unterkühlt er wird
noch zeigen dass er emotionen hat dann
wenn es um seinen gegenspieler geht
friedrich merz unionsfraktionschef
atomkraftwerke nur in reserve halten für
märz ein fauler ampel kompromiss die
lage spitzt sich in den nächsten tagen
wochen und monaten möglicherweise
dramatisch zu und sie wissen es sie
haben die gesprächspartner die ihnen das
gesagt haben es dürfte alles andere als
eine übertreibung sein ich sage ihnen
herr bundeskanzler stoppen sie diesen
irrsinn aus ihrer koalition so lange wir
die zeit dafür noch stolz gibt der union
die schuld für die energie misere
erwähnt aber nicht die junior rolle der
spd in der merkel regierung die union
habe immer wieder blockiert sie war
unfair ausbau der noch neuen
energieverwaltung türen sie haben
abwehrkämpfe geführt gegen jede einzelne
windkraftanlage und jeder ab der kampf
der letzten jahre schadet unserem land
noch heute das vorsieht
wir holen jetzt nach was jahrelang
versäumt wurde dass nämlich die
priorität auf dem ausbau der
erneuerbaren der energieeinsparung der
energieeffizienz liegen und daher reicht
es auch mit ihren polemisieren gegen
robert habe denn der hat gerade verdammt
viel zu tun haben muss tatsächlich
zwischendurch weg sein akw notreserve
plan wackelt die afg holte zum
rundumschlag aus die regierung ruiniere
das land fahre ist gegen die wand und
wenn sie nicht willens oder fähig sind
ihren kurs zu ändern
dann treten sie bitte ab denn das wäre
das beste entlastungspaket für unser
land
auch unzufrieden die linke sie
kritisiert die geplanten entlastungen
96 milliarden seien zu wenig im
vergleich zum sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr
dafür die schuldenbremse ausgesetzt für
den besetzungen der bevölkerung wird sie
es nicht die generaldebatte im
wesentlichen ein duell zwischen merz und
schulz wir kommen wohl durch den winter
sagt der kanzler der zweifel im plenum
ist vielstimmig und bleibt
zwischen bundeswirtschaftsminister
habeck und der eon-tochter preussen
elektra ist ein streit in brand der
akw-betreiber hält es technisch für
nicht möglich
atommeiler in not reserve zu halten
genau das hatte habeck am montag
angekündigt für die atomkraftwerke isar
2 und neckarwestheim 2 beide akw sollen
wie geplant ende dezember ihren betrieb
einstellen aber im notfall wieder strom
produzieren
das preußen elektra das nicht für
machbar hält habe er mit einiger
verwunderung zur kenntnis genommen so
habeck heute
theo koll in berlin was ist da los tja
da kreuzen gerade im konzern muss der
zuständige minister die klingen und das
auf offener bühne vor einem winter der
möglichen energieknappheit aktuell wird
versucht den politischen schaden zu
verringern indem von einer reihe von
missverständnissen gesprochen wird
offensichtlich aber gibt es deutliche
unterschiede also ob das akw isar 2 1
sogenannte notreserve machbar ist also
wie von herweck vorgeschlagen das
kraftwerk ende des jahres runterzufahren
und in einer art kaltreserve zu schicken
und dann nur bei bedarf wieder
hochzufahren um einen drohenden
stromausfall zu verhindern oder ob wie
die betreiber jetzt schreiben ein
solcher reservebetrieb nicht möglich ist
im moment lässt es auch diverse
spekulationen hier in berlin ins kraut
schießen beispielsweise ob der minister
die frühzeitigen warnungen des konzerns
übergangen hat oder ob der betreiber
vielleicht statt der staatlichen
entschädigungen für eine notreserve
betrieb er auf den höheren gewinnen bei
dauerbetrieb zielt in jedem fall gilt
aber für habeck hat der vielzitierte
heiße herbst jetzt schon begonnen danke
für diese einschätzung theo koll
die eu kommission plant einen preis
deckel für importe von russischem gas
kam mannschaft tut ihnen droht sollte so
ein preis deckel kommen werde russland
kein gas mehr nach europa liefern
gleichzeitig für putin im westen unter
führung der usa vor in ein regelrechtes
sanktions fieber verfallen zu sein
unsere korrespondentin für begann über
die frage inwieweit die bisherigen
strafmaßnahmen russland treffen
seine schätze gehen zur neige erzählt
barbesitzer sergej newski seit dem
frühjahr als moskau die ukraine über
viel liefern viele westliche
destillerien nicht mehr nach russland
auch lokal gebrautes bier drohte knapp
zu werden
das hauptproblem sind die zutaten die
lieferungen von malz hefe und so weiter
aber es wurde ein ausweg gefunden sie
arbeiten jetzt mit ländern zusammen die
russlandfreundlich eingestellt sind
schwieriger sind ersatz lieferanten zu
finden bei mikrochips und flugzeugteilen
die westlichen sanktionen werfen
russland technologisch zurück 8 o was
beispielsweise baut jetzt autos ohne abs
und airbag der automobilmarkt habe quasi
aufgehört zu existieren und nicht nur
der urteilt wirtschaftsexperte dimitri
potapenko die zeiten unsicher das geld
knapp das bremst die kauflaune
der immobilienmarkt ist eingebrochen die
verkäufe sind und bis zu 97 prozent zu
ausgegangen etwa genauso stark die
verkäufe von neuwagen die inflation
liegt schon nach offiziellen angaben bei
14 prozent das bruttoinlandsprodukt sank
um vier prozent im vergleich zum
vorjahreszeitraum
die sanktionen langsam zeigen sie
wirkung und werden zum reizthema für den
präsidenten der kasten ist im sanktions
fieber versucht unverhohlen aggressiv
anderen ländern seien verhaltens modell
aufzuzwingen sie ihrer souveränität zu
berauben
angst um den job die ungewisse zukunft
seine gäste würden viel darüber reden in
einem kann sie beruhigen wodka werde es
immer geben
in der ukraine geht der beschuss am
atomkraftwerk sa borussia weiter es gebe
brände und stromausfälle in der anlage
so der ukrainische regionalgouverneure
genco
angesichts der gefahr hatte
un-generalsekretär
görisch gestern eine schutzzone und um
das kraftwerk gefordert expertinnen und
experten der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde
hatten das kraftwerk vergangene woche
untersucht sie beschrieben die situation
als unhaltbar und warnen vor der
erheblichen gefahr eines atomunfalls
der krieg hat viele folgen auch für
diesel-fahrzeuge die transportbranche
mit ihrer lkw flotte schlägt alarm
adblue wird knapp es wird benötigt um
abgase bei modernen dieselmotoren zu
reinigen
gewonnen wird der zusatz aus ammoniak
bei der energieintensiven herstellung
muss teures erdgas eingesetzt werden
wenig wirtschaftlich für hersteller
deshalb stoppen einige die produktion
folge der preis ab werk für adblue hat
sich von herbst 20 21 wie sie sehen
können von 13 auf derzeit rund 99 euro
gut für 78 den zusatz benötigen 90
prozent aller laster lena sünder bruch
vor allem sie sind auf adblue angewiesen
spediteure doch einige lkw könnten schon
bald lahmgelegt sein sagt der
bundesverband logistik und warnt vor
versorgungsengpässen
in deutschland sind jeden tag circa
800.000 lkws unterwegs die uns mit den
gütern des täglichen bedarfs versorgen
das sind über 70 der güter die mit dem
lkw transportiert werden wenn diese lkws
kein and blue nachschub bekommen bleiben
sie stehen und können nicht mehr
weiterbetrieben werden mit allen
auswirkungen vom supermarkt regal über
die apotheke bis hin zur krankenhaus
logistik auch busse bau und
landmaschinen benötigen adblue und circa
1,4 millionen diesel-pkw der abgasnormen
euro5 und vor allem euro 6 schätzt der
adac
doch wegen der hohen gaspreise drosseln
immer mehr erzeuger ihre produktion des
abgasreinigung der größte deutsche
autohersteller die stickstoff werke
piesteritz in wittenberg hat die
herstellung ausgesetzt die gasanlage ist
ein wesentlicher beitrag warum wir nicht
produzieren können wirtschaftlich
produzieren können die gasanlage ist
eine deutsche spezialität
im übrigen ist die gas ist der gaspreis
natürlich überall in europa gestiegen
aber in deutschland wäre nicht gedeckelt
in frankreich deckelt dass der staat den
gaspreis in polen ist es angedacht in
deutschland nicht die unternehmen
drängen auf staatliche hilfe aber das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium sieht
derzeit keine mangel lage bei der
produktion des diesel reinigers eines
steht fest die preise steigen und
steigen
was genau ist adblue und was geschieht
wenn der stoff knapp wird antworten und
weitere informationen haben wir online
jederzeit nachzulesen in unserer zdf
heute app
deutschland leidet unter
fachkräftemangel wie noch nie corona die
demografische entwicklung weil
geeignetes personal fehlt müssen einige
unternehmen schon ihre geschäfte
einschränken im august gab es fast 900
1000 unbesetzte arbeitsstellen ein
anstieg um etwas mehr als 100.000 im
vergleich zum vorjahr besonders gesucht
fachkräfte im bereich verkehr logistik
und weit oben außerdem verkaufs berufe
wie auch gesundheitsberufe was also tun
antworten suchte heute die
bundesregierung mit wirtschaft und
gewerkschaften andré schubert berichtet
hier sorgt künftig eine moderne
fußbodenheizung für wärme und
wohlbefinden als fachbetrieb ist die
firma krone aus berlin hellersdorf
zuständig spezialisiert auf gas wasser
klima die auftragsbücher sind voll so
weit so gut oder
trotz voller auftragsbücher haben wir
eine schwierige situation also nicht nur
wegen der fachkräfte die uns fehlen
sollen auch wegen zu ergebnissen dieser
ganzen situation in der wir gerade leben
diese ganzen lieferketten sind
zusammengebrochen wir haben das material
ist nicht verfügbar der
bundesarbeitsminister hat sich vor ort
die lage erklären lassen nimmt vor allem
die erkenntnisse über die fehlenden
fachkräfte mit zum heutigen gipfel der
bundesregierung bei dem mit wirtschaft
und gewerkschaften lösungen erarbeitet
werden sollen klar ist einige probleme
sind hausgemacht
die größte quelle aber für
fachkräftesicherung im inland das ist
eine höhere frauenerwerbsquote liegen
was das arbeitszeitvolumen betrifft
stichwort vereinbarkeit von beruf und
familie aber auch fragen die wir im
steuerrecht zu klären haben und dafür zu
sorgen dass mehr frauen und männer in
deutschland die chance haben zu arbeiten
außerdem brauche es qualifizierte
zuwanderung die handwerksverbände
fordern zusätzlich eine neuorientierung
ein umdenken im bereich der beruflichen
bildung wir dürfen nicht weiter dem
bildungs mantra unterliegen dass man nur
mit einem studium erfolgreich sein kann
im beruf und in der gesellschaft sondern
auch mit der beruflichen bildung ganz
ganz viel erreichen kann handwerk hat
goldenen boden so heißt ein sprichwort
momentan ist allerdings nur eins klar
deutschland fehlen fachkräfte
wenn sie auf dem land wohnen kennen sie
das wahrscheinlich man will einen termin
beim arzt machen aber wird vertröstet
oder gleich ganz ab gewesen der mangel
an ärztinnen und ärzten ist aber nicht
nur in dünn besiedelten regionen ein
problem sondern deutschlandweit und ein
finanzieller anreiz neue patienten
aufzunehmen will das
bundesgesundheitsministerium
abschaffen dagegen gab es heute proteste
in berlin romanesco war am östlichen
berliner stadtrand hat gabriela stempel
ihre hausarztpraxis eine ganze reihe
kollegen im kiezes in den ruhestand
gegangen
ohne nachfolger die suche nach einem
neuen arzt ist hier beschwerlich
geworden ich habe da und dort und
überall angefragte sehr oft hat man das
gesehen dass im moment nehmen wir keine
patienten augen eine medizinische
vorgeschichte zu kompliziert es gab
tausende würden hätten bei der hausärzte
werden immer mehr neue patienten
vorstellig weit über 1000 hat sie schon
deutlich mehr als der durchschnitt dann
der neue patienten regelung erhielt sie
für die neuen bislang einen finanziellen
bonus sie eher zusätzliches personal
eingestellt zum jahreswechsel will das
gesundheitsministerium die regelung nun
streichen die ärztin fühlt sich bestraft
kann ich noch ein bluthochdruck
patienten kein haus aus hier draußen hat
noch ein rezept ausstellen kann ich noch
eine diagnostik machen ja also ich habe
kein problem
zusätzlich zu arbeiten aber ich möchte
dann auch wie jeder andere berufe auch
das auch bezahlt kriegen aus protest
gegen die pläne blieben in berlin heute
rund 2000 praxen geschlossen
ärztevertreter warnen vor langen
wartezeiten
aufnahmestopps für patienten wenn die
streichung kommt der spitzenverband der
gesetzlichen krankenversicherung hält
dagegen einen dreistelligen
millionenbetrag aber die maßnahme
gekostet ohne spürbaren effekt eine
bonusregelung für eine neuerung die
nichts verbessert halten wir nicht für
angemessen deshalb ist es konsequent
dass die politik genau diese regelung
jetzt wieder streichen möchte wird die
arztsuche künftig beschwerlicher für
patienten gewissheit wird es wohl erst
geben wenn die neue patienten regelung
abgeschafft ist
nach dem fischsterben in der oder gibt
es jetzt in warnung von dem gewässer
gehe keine gefahr mehr aus sagen die
behörden und hoben einschränkungen wie
das angelverbot auf nur um nebenarm der
alten oder bleiben sie bestehen seit
anfang august waren aus dem deutsch
polnischen grenzfluss tonnenweise toter
fisch geborgen worden
fachleute gehen davon aus dass ein
zusammenspiel von niedrigwasser hohen
temperaturen und salz einleitungen die
ausbreitung einer giftigen eigenart
begünstigt hat
nach brasilien vor genau 200 jahren
wurde das südamerikanische land
unabhängig von der kolonialmacht
portugal und das wird heute groß
gefeiert der rechtsextreme präsident
boyzone aru versucht die feierlichkeiten
dabei für den wahlkampf zu nutzen
anfang oktober wird ein neuer präsident
gewählt und laut umfragen liegt derzeit
bei sonos herausforderer der linke ex
präsident lula vorne über das duell
christopher karat
eigentlich sollte der nationalfeiertag
ein tag für alle brasilianer sein doch
hier an der copacabana in rio ist es
eine wahlkampfveranstaltung der anhänger
von präsident bolz jahre später will er
sie hier besuchen kommen doch schon am
morgen nach dem staatsakt in brasilia
setzt er den ton des tages angriff statt
einheit
wir wissen dass wir uns in einem kampf
zwischen gut und böse befinden etwas
böses das 14 jahre lang in unserem land
herrschte
gemeint ist brasiliens linke um
ex-präsident lula dessen amtszeit war
geprägt von einem beispiellosen
korruptionsskandal aber auch von
wirtschaftlichem aufschwung und
umfassenden sozialprogrammen
daran will er anknüpfen
das land das ich hinterlassen habe ist
ein land nachdem sich die menschen
sehnen es war ein land mit ein land in
dem die menschen das recht hatten ein
würdevolles leben zu führen
gut drei wochen vor der wahl liegt lula
in den umfragen deutlich vor ball zu
nahrung doch viele anhänger des
präsidenten zweifeln dass an es gibt nur
eine möglichkeit dass der präsident
verliert das es betrug gibt an der
valoren
in den letzten monaten der präsident vor
szenario immer wieder zweifel eine
rechtmäßigkeit der wahl geäußert sollte
er sie verlieren ein archiv das
anscheinend bei vielen seiner anhänger
verfängt wie man auch hier auf der
demonstration sehen könnten transparente
wahlen steht da bisher gab es keinen
grund daran zu zweifeln dass
brasilianische system gilt als sicher
doch die rhetorik des balls szenario
lagers bereitet manchen sorge was am tag
nach einer welchen niederlage passieren
könnte
kommen wir zurück nach deutschland zum
fußball na wat da gab es ja heute den
ersten trainer-rauswurf in der
bundesliga saison
domenico tedesco muss gehen letzte
saison hatte er noch mit leipzig den dfb
pokal und damit den ersten titel für rb
überhaupt geholt jetzt aber
enttäuschende bundesliga start und nach
der 1 4-klatsche gestern abend gegen
donezk war feierabend
nach dem pokalsieg im mai wird ein klub
boss mintzlaff und tedesco noch
unzertrennlich heute morgen gab minister
auf die entlassung des trainers bekannt
nach dem 0 2 4 in frankfurt stand
tedesco gestern gegen don jetzt mächtig
unter druck dass ein sonst so
zuverlässiger torwart gulati dann
sogleich patzte machte es nicht leichter
frühe rückstand hoffnung kann nur kurz
auf als sie mag an kurz nach dem wechsel
der ausgleich gelang doch nachdem orban
den ball nur eine minute später ins
eigene netz abfälschte bei aller glaube
da hin entstand 1 zu 4 und die üblichen
fragen zur drohenden entlassung jungs
haben alles gegeben hat man es rein
gehauen und über alles andere mache ich
mir auch keine gedanken bin ich da der
absolut falsche ansprechpartner seit
heute wissen wir es ist vorbei favorit
für die nachfolge
dortmund ehemaliger trainer marco rose
völlig überraschend dagegen der
rausschmiss von thomas tuchel bei
chelsea der hatte ja mit dem fc letztes
jahr sogar die champions league gewonnen
der start in diese saison aber unter den
erwartungen der vereinsführung tuchel
muskeln
beste stimmung dagegen beim bvb nach dem
klaren heimsieg gestern abend gegen
kopenhagen und wieder war es ein
überragender marco reus der die
dortmunder in führung brachte und in der
83 minute setzte den juke bellingham mit
dem 13 0 den schlussstrich unter einen
gelungenen schwarz-gelben
champions-league-auftakt
und alle tore alle begegnungen
zusammengefasst auch die von bayern
frankfurt und leverkusen heute abend zu
sehen bei uns im zdf um 23 uhr im
sportstudio champions league die erste
niederlage der deutschen basketballer
bei der heim-wm gegen slowenien oder
besser gesagt gegen luca dotti
36 punkte machte der nba star gestern
abend beim 88 zu 80 sieg die deutsche
mannschaft konnte nur phasenweise
mithalten hatte sich aber ja bereits
zuvor für die em-endrunde
qualifiziert ja und die slowenen sind
jetzt auch noch gruppensieger nachdem
sie heute abend gerade eben die
franzosen auch noch besiegt haben
gaggenau tisch ist und diese lottozahlen
wurden heute gezogen sie lauten 8 11 14
16 40 41 superzahl ist die drei weiter
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und zdf text auf seite 5 157
langer sehnt ist da ja der regen der von
westen auf zieht allerdings kommt der
vielerorts gleich in so großen menge
runter das überschwemmungen drohen mehr
gleich von katja horne fahren das heute
journal mit marietta slomka können sie
um 21 45 sehen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend was auf diesen satelliten
film ins auge sticht ist das auge des
ehemaligen hurricanes daniel und daniel
wird sich in unserer wettergeschehen in
europa einmischen aber erst in einigen
tagen für uns interessant sind dagegen
diese wolken die hier von frankreich
langsam zu uns heranziehen der darunter
verbirgt sich ergiebiger dauerregen und
dieser regen ist auch mit gewittern
durchsetzt das geht in der zweiten
nachthälfte los die letzten regenschauer
und gewitter von heute nachmittag ziehen
dann in der nacht ostwärts ab die
temperaturen sinken am oberrhein bis 17
grad zwölf grad sind es zb im westerwald
oder auch am alpenrand und morgen ist es
dann nicht mehr so waren wie heute das
sind schon fast herbsttemperaturen 23
grad in der lausitz 22 bis 24 grad am
rhein kühler bleibt es dagegen von den
küsten bis nach ostbayern mit nur so 16
bis 19 grad daran sehen sie auch ganz
schön wo es morgen am kräftigsten regnet
das ist nämlich gerade in diesem
streifen der fall dieser regen kann
wirklich heftig seien 60 bis 80 liter
regen pro quadratmeter bis morgen abend
sind möglich besonders richtung sachsen
anhalt aber auch in sachsen und im
südlichen brandenburg auch in den
nächsten tagen geht es mit schauern und
gewittern weiter der regen ist dann
weniger heftig genannt